but first for all the Conservative
Party's divisions they the brexit labor
has some difficulties of its own the
fundamental problem of having a pro EU
membership that many voters who back
leave has left the party walking a
delicate tightrope which is increasingly
looking like it could snap and the time
for choosing a side is fast approaching
well to talk about that and lots more
we're joined now by Jeremy Corbyn thank
you very much for being with us my
pleasure thank you for inviting me well
we finally know what the government's
plan for brexit looks like so is that
something that the Labour Party could
support no we can't support it it
doesn't meet our tests we don't believe
it meets the needs of the country we do
think it would be much better if the
Labour alternative of access to a market
a guaranteed permanent form of customs
union with the European Union and
protection of rights in this country
would be a better deal for this country
as a whole so what specifically is it in
the text that doesn't meet those tests
that you disagree with well a number of
things that are in this agreement that
are simply not acceptable one is that
the issue of Northern Ireland is not
dealt with because it will mean that
there will be a border down the Irish
Sea unless an agreement is reached as in
what do you have an agreement with the
European Union for a customs union for
the whole of the UK that has to be the
basis for optimism well but we have no
say in that until such time as a
backstop has been agreed and during that
period the EU calls all the shots and
the EU decides whether we're allowed to
change that arrangement or not it's a
one-way agreement it's quite risky the
issue of course is that you know I know
how critical the moment is and I
understand that you have concerns such
as the whether or not we can leave the
bat-ropes backstop unilaterally but are
those concerns big enough that you are
risking no deal because that's the
reality of your position isn't it no
it's not the reality at all we would say
we'll vote against this deal because it
doesn't meet our test we do not believe
it serves the interests of this country
therefore the government would have to
go back to the EU and renegotiate
rapidly they've had after all since the
referendum
2016 to undertake serious negotiations
and here we are now 131 days to go and
they're finally presenting something to
Parliament it's not a very acceptable
way of running things but you know don't
you that the increase the likelihood of
No Deal increases if you don't support
this deal and we can just have a look at
what you've said previously about the
risk of of No Deal you've said that if
we vote again that if we don't have a
brexit deal that would be a national
disaster so are you risking a national
disaster that's all we're saying now to
the government you haven't got a
majority in parliament for this you
don't have a majority support in the
whole country you have to go back and do
something better indeed there are
already the Prime Minister's and
providers in her own cabinet who are
saying well actually we'll have to go
and negotiate something so what
specifically do you want so if for
example you were talking there about
being able to you know that to really
leave the backstop if that was something
that the government could negotiate
would you then support it what I would
say to the government is you've got to
get in place a permanent customs
arrangement with the European Union
otherwise we lose on jobs we lose on
investment and we lose on future
economic development it's a relationship
indeed does that but they've also got to
be very very clear about rights and
objectives put it two ways one is the
government has embraced without any
question whatsoever
EU rules on state aid it hasn't embraced
without any question the issue of
workers rights
if European workers rights improve arts
can deteriorate at the same time what I
want to see is absolutely an alignment
with Europe on workers rights or we go
further than that the danger is that we
end up with the movement which many on
the Tory right want which is a
deregulated economy moving further and
further away from what is our major
trading partner Europe so if you have to
I'm just trying to really pin you down
on exactly what it would be that gets
you over the line and to support the
deal because I'm at I'm still slightly
unclear on what exactly it is that would
set what mean you'd come back and say
okay Prime Minister will support there's
five hundred pages in this document much
of which are actually quite fake where's
the guarantee on environmental
protections where's the guarantee on
consumer protections where's the
guarantee on work
right where's the guarantee but there
are look at me guarantees they were the
level playing field commitments think of
all those people working in
manufacturing industry in Britain and
those thousands of jobs in supply chains
all across the Midlands in the North who
will be very worried that their
companies are going to either dis invest
or not invest in the future and will see
a continuing rundown of our
manufacturing industry what we want is
expanding economy and a fairer the level
playing field commitments are in that
withdrawal agreement have you read the
yes hundred pages I've read that a lot
of it not every last word I've read many
summaries and many other analyses as I'm
sure you have as well yeah and so just
to and really try and clarify them so is
there anything you can say specifically
that if tourism a comes back with these
points you will vote for the data we've
put it to the government many many times
I believe there is a majority in
parliament that would support a
permanent customs arrangement with the
European Union I believe there is a
majority in parliament would want to see
a guarantee of rights on both sides of
the channel and there's absolutely
majority in parliament as not want to
see a deal that brings in in effect a
financial border across the Irish Sea
and can practically stopped as of this
moment the arithmetic in Parliament is
such that brexit has been triggered at
article 15 we voted for article 50 52 in
order to give respect to the referendum
and I was asked this question by dis
vehicle what I said was we couldn't stop
it because we don't have the votes in
Parliament to do so what I want to do is
say to the government you've had all
this time to negotiate you're not going
to get this thing through Parliament
don't waste another two weeks on this go
back now because you must have read the
rooms in Parliament you can't get it
through I just want to go back to this
point and get some real clarity on it we
can have a look and what you said in the
interview that you mentioned when you
asked about brexit you said we can't
stop it and your brexit secretary then
said brexit can be stopped so who's
right because I was little bit confused
well I said we can't stop it because on
our own obviously we can't
keya said brexit can't be stopped
clearly a vast majority of people could
if they will agree to do so but the
point I'm making you to say that you
can't stop breakfast on our own money
flavour is one what am i into the
campaign for people's vote there would
be well people people's vote is a second
questions and it's actually the the
issue is there was a referendum in 2016
a majority voted to leave the EU there
are many reasons why people voted I
don't think you call a referendum and
then say you don't like the result you
go away from it you've got to understand
why people voted and try and negotiate
the best deal you can I do not believe
this comes as negotiated the best deal
it can all options are on the table in
the future so it's no brexit better than
no deal then I don't think that's an
option we're gonna get given the issue
is we're moving up towards the end of
March when Britain will be leaving the
EU under the current proposals this
government has failed in negotiations
failed to protect things and at the same
time actually made this country much
worse I mean this is a week when the UN
has condemned Britain for unacceptable
levels of poverty what does that say
about this government what does it say
about this country at the same time
though you are the leader of the
Opposition at this critical moment you
have a responsibility to try and drive
the debate it's one thing just toasting
you duck out and say actually I don't
think we're going to be given that
option we don't have the numbers to get
it through but you are in position where
you have a large number of MPs you have
a large number party members you could
drive the debate if you wanted to we are
driving a debate about the kind of
society we want in Britain we're driving
a debate about the kind of relationship
with Europe in the future well that we
forced the government we forced the
government onto the whole concept of a
transition we forced them into accepting
amendments in Parliament on the
meaningful vote at the end of it labour
has been absolutely on this case ever
since the referee you think there should
be a second referendum what do you think
I think it's an option for the future
but it's not an option for today because
we've got a referendum tomorrow what's
it gonna be on what's the question going
to but would you like the question to be
on would you like remains to be on the
ballot paper I think that the tests
against the government have to be put
now and that's what we're doing
the government must go back and
renegotiate and see what it comes back
in Parliament must look at that at that
time I think to do anything else now
would be to ignore the reality of the
situation is that this government's had
all this time to negotiate and hasn't
really achieved these I'm keen to talk
about your position though not just that
we know what you think about the
government's position but I'm just keen
to examine Labour's position as well how
would you vote if there was a second I
voted in the first referendum to remain
I campaigned for a main and reform
indeed I had a debate in this very
building to discuss exactly that issue I
think there are reforms needed in the
European Union I think in the future we
could have a good effective relationship
with the European Union which would give
us a permanent customs union which would
give us a trade agreement and above all
would also ensure that we fully
cooperate with them on Environment
Protection well I don't know how it's
going to vote what the options would be
at that time but I wanted us to remain
in the EU that was my vote in that
referendum
okay now you often say that you want to
see a general election it's very hard to
see in many ways how that would happen
yes over your shadow Chancellor John
McDonnell admitted that because of the
fixed term Parliament act it would be
very difficult and it's very unlikely
isn't that we're going to get a general
election can you admit that now no it's
not unlikely at all this government
cannot control Parliament it doesn't
have a majority the DUP have walked away
from their fundamental agreement on the
European Union so it's very through how
would get to a general election we could
get to a general election of the
government resigned and called one we
could get to general if you get to
general election if two thirds of MPs
voted to have one under the fixed term
policies there like last time around
nobody expected the general election the
Prime Minister decided to call one
because she thought she could win it and
do very well the result was rather
different the one that she expected I
think the country needs stability it
needs an opportunity to have a say on
who it wants to conduct the negotiation
of the European Union and who it wants
to deal with that chronic social issues
facing grim I mentioned the UN report on
poverty isn't that pretty damning of our
country but how you say you say that
it's not unlikely but that two-thirds of
MPs would need to address for it so
I mean you got really except we used we
allow you into power can you we will
continue to the optimistic we will
continue to press the whole issues on
Europe and on social justice in Britain
we will continue to demand the British
people have a say in who their
government should be negotiating these
arrangements I don't believe this
government has negotiated fairly or
effectively or kept Parliament properly
informed of it and indeed as now co-op
was an agreement in which we pay a great
deal of money and have very little say
in anything for the whole of the
transition period and indeed give the EU
control over arrangements in just three
months do you really think you could
negotiate a better deal than the
government I mean is that fantasy
politics it's taken two years to get to
this point the EU is very used to xi tau
stuff look at the way the Lisbon treaty
was negotiated renegotiated and
renegotiated again they the issue has to
be you go back to Europe and say listen
our Parliament doesn't agree with this
and doesn't accept it people of this
country don't there are jobs on both
sides of the channel at risk here we
need an agreement a serious sensible
agreement and I believe the labor
options are the serious ones that could
achieve that so just go back to the EU
and ask them very nicely if they'd give
us a better deal I mean it's the course
isn't it they want an agreement just as
much as everybody else does the problem
is this government has not negotiated an
effective agreement with them so you
think you could do it in three months we
would go there straight away and there
is a transition period that's been
agreed anyway so there would be some
opportunities there but of course the
Hat you have to go back and say look
what's been agreed so far between our
government and the EU is not acceptable
to the British Parliament or I suspect
the British people and it hasn't yet
been tested in the EU Parliament either
your sixth ask because it's something
you mentioned at the beginning of the
interview and it's something that many
people just don't think could be
possibly achieved by anybody including
yourselves perhaps do you really think
you'd be able to get a deal that would
meet those six tests including one of
them which is that it would delete
deliver the exact same benefits as being
in the single
when how do you get that and that if you
that if you have a trade agreement and a
customs union a customs union with the
EU then you do get the same benefits of
trade you do get the same benefits of
the way in which our manufacturing is so
inextricably linked where did those
words come from the government
themselves it came from David Davis he
was came from David Davis yeah well he
wasn't even the last brexit secretary
you can't be saying you basically he was
the last but what it was the last what
one brexit secretary
well quite you were saying you're basing
your whole policy on breaks that last
but one protein back at them what they
said and we believe it to be possible
this is more about them playing politics
no no I quoted David Davis's words we're
very serious about this we're very
serious about our concerns over jobs and
investment and trade with the European
Union the future the issue and that we
have of course is that you say you want
to deliver the exact same benefits of
this legal market but that goes against
what we've been hearing from Brussels
for months I mean we can look for
example company it's something that Jean
Claude's yonko that you use most senior
official said on this the deal that will
be offered to the UK it should not be a
deal as advantageous as membership so I
don't understand how you can get the
exact same benefits well that was his
view we have a different view I don't
want to say wrong what I say is we
believe we could get the same benefits
on trade on customs union with the
European Union
why would they give you that because
it's in the interest of people on both
sides of the channel to do so it's all
can their interest to show that you're
better off in the EU I think it's in
their interests to have a very good and
close relationship with the countries
around the EU as they attempting to do
with all other neighboring countries and
I think that is the right way forward so
why aren't they in that case I'm giving
the best deal possible to this current
government if it is in their interest as
well that's the that's a question you
have to put to the EU negotiators I've
had many discussions with Michel Barnier
explained what our position is explained
what we would wish to do in government
and explained also that we would not be
a government that's trying to look over
our shoulders do sweetheart deals with
somebody else which would result in
a lowering of our conditions in this
country workers consumers and
environmental rights and indeed
president mark Rome has joined in this
yesterday and said he's very concerned
about Britain reducing its environmental
protection measures okay
now I'm interested in your own personal
journey when it comes to the EU no you
voted to leave the European Economic
Community in the 1975 yes referendum you
oppose the creation of the European
Union in the Maastricht Treaty he voted
against no I want to oppose the
Maastricht Treaty because it was
bringing in an unaccountable central
bank and it was moving in the direction
of a free market Europe but you abide by
parallel I strongly supported these
social measures that were brought in by
the European Union which mrs. Thatcher
so strongly opposed so I do support a
social Europe and actually I've probably
spent more time meeting European
socialist parties and any other labor
leader but it's fair to say you've had
your concerns I'm interested in your
have you changed your mind would you
consider yourself to be a euro skeptic
where are you I've always been in favor
of social cooperation across Europe I've
always been in favor of better workers
rights I strongly supported the whole
social Chapter agenda that was brought
in in the European Union what I opposed
was the development of free-market
economics in Europe what I opposed was
the state aid rules which limit to
differing extents the ability of a
government to intervene on its own
economy like we would want to to protect
the steel industry and also have
concerns about some of the competition
rules particularly in relation to things
like postal services and rail services
would you describe yourself as a euro
skeptic I describe myself as a socialist
who wants to see social justice in this
country and across Europe and I will be
in Lisbon at the beginning of December
with fellow socialist parties making
exactly that message and exactly that
case we have to work with people across
Europe do you think that the EU should
have learned and listened when it came
to the Bronx that referendum do you
think that they've taken the right
lessons I think a lot of people need to
learn from them how about from Brussels
at Brussels and
I think they often have actually to some
extent and indeed I've discussed this
with them Michel Barnier and others I
said well actually the communities we
have in Britain that have seen no
investment since the end of the - strike
that have seen the loss of jobs that
have seen the replacement of good jobs
with zero hours contracts it's not that
different in parts of northern France
it's not that different in parts of
eastern Germany communities that gain
nothing from public investment nothing
from new infrastructure nothing from any
investment in hope for young people are
likely to be against the institution's
that they believe have failed to deliver
it for them and I think there's a big
lesson for all of us and that's why was
the third time I've mentioned it the UN
report on poverty in Britain is
devastating devastating of the economic
model that we've adopted in this country
in all your years in Parliament you've
probably haven't seen many weeks quite
like the one we've just experienced in
Westminster might be fair to say it's
been a pretty unusual week that's been
very fair to say yes you were called in
to see the Prime Minister after she had
that cabinet meeting what happened we
have a quite short discussion solely
about parliamentary process in which I
made the point that I thought Parliament
should have sufficient time between the
EU council and any vote in Parliament
for members to digest whatever comes out
of the EU Council which of course hasn't
yet had been held and our select
committees to have a chance to examine
it and that the whatever statement or
resolution the government put to the
house had to be open to amendments and I
sent a letter to the Prime Minister
signed by all opposition parties except
for the DUP on that was it a cordial
meeting yes it was very short actually
no carpet even I had a very nice glass
of water but I was offered a very nice
cup of tea or coffee if I wish to and
since I don't drink I wasn't I don't
know if I was going to be offered drinks
or not and I just - your reflections as
well on the week that the Prime Minister
has had she's faced resignations from
her cabinet she's faced no-confidence
letters from her own MP I mean this is
something that you may have a bit of
empathy for
you of course have struggled to form a
fun bench before you've faced a
no-confidence motion against you do you
feel sorry for the Prime Minister a
politics is full of lots of thrills and
spills there is a quite big difference
between laboring conservative parties in
that labor is largely a member led
organisation and my mandate came from
party members and I appealed to them in
2016 and gained an increased level of
support
I don't do personal attacks and a
personal abuse and you notice I've said
nothing personal in criticism I do
understand what people go through and I
understand all of that but I do also
understand the responsibility of
Parliament and government to deliver for
the people that have put us there in the
first place
those people are struggling with jobs
poverty mental health all those issues
where we systematically shortchanging
them they're the people we should be
thinking about
do you respect opponents I respect all
politicians ok Jeremy Corbyn thank you
very much thank you